Nous voici avec ces privilèges, j'ai mentionné pendant la prière de nous plonger davantage
dans cette déclaration qui faisait partie d'une confession de l'Église primitive
et qui cherche à résumer notre foi de manière glorieuse, cette citation d'une confession
qui était aussi un chant et qui nous dit sans contredit les mystères de la piété
grand, verset 16, c'est lui qui a été manifesté en chair, justifié par l'esprit, vu des anges
précieux et gentils, cru dans les mondes et élevé dans la gloire.
C'est très intéressant de remarquer comment nous avons pris l'habitude en tant que nation
occidentale qui a été christianisée historiquement, de célébrer Noël et de nous concentrer à
Noël surtout sur l'incarnation du Fils des dieux.
Donc ce qui est intéressant à nous rappeler, c'est que dans ces passages, cette déclaration
confessionnelle qui, de manière très précise et concise, présente notre foi, bien sûr qu'elle
met beaucoup d'emphase sur cette grande révélation qui a été la manifestation du Fils des dieux.
Un chair, elle ne permet pas toutefois que l'incarnation du Fils des dieux soit vue seule.
Elle est vue dans un ensemble qui a une progression qui va culminer avec le fait que c'est Jésus-Christ
qui est incarné, qui a vécu la vie parfaite en chair à notre place, qui est mort à la croix,
qui a été réclamé par les Saint-Esprits comme fils des dieux, qui a reçu les témoignages des anges à propos de son incarnation,
qui a été prêché, qui est encore prêché aux gentils, aux païens, à toutes les nations,
qui a été cru dans les mondes en étant le seul royaume qui a perduré la montée et la chute de tout autre empire.
Et qui va continuer à être le seul royaume irrésistible jusqu'à la fin.
Mais ça va culminer sur le fait que le Christ a été élevé dans la gloire.
Et la sentence ou la confession va s'arrêter ici,
n'ont pour suggérer que son œuvre est arrêtée lorsqu'il a été élevé dans la gloire.
Mais tout simplement pour dire qu'à partir d'ici, nous sommes devant une position
qui est la constante et la réalité du peuple des dieux pour toujours jusqu'au retour du Christ.
C'est par la fin de l'histoire le fait qu'il soit élevé dans la gloire.
Il s'est élevé dans la gloire, il est assis sur les trônes des dieux
pour occuper sans aucune résistance, sans aucune restriction,
la gouvernance de tout l'univers et de toute l'histoire
à faveur de la progression de son Église.
à faveur de la progression de la foi,
du développement de la foi de chaque chrétien individuel
et de la progression glorieuse de son Église.
Et donc c'est les points culminants pour nous,
ce que nous allons considérer aujourd'hui.
Cette dernière facette élevée dans la gloire.
Et on devrait nous demander
et à partir d'aujourd'hui prendre la résolution
de ne jamais fragmenter
ou séparer l'identité de notre Seigneur Jésus de son œuvre
et non plus fragmenter l'ensemble de son œuvre.
Et donc si à Noël nous avons plutôt la tendance
à nous concentrer sur l'incarnation
qui est déjà très glorieuse en soi,
pendant toute la vie de la foi chrétienne,
nous devrions nous plonger dans la compréhension
de la révélation de ces mystères
qui est traité ici comme les mystères les plus glorieux,
les sublimes mystères
qui dépassent tout autre intérêt
qu'on aurait pu avoir dans la vie.
On cherche à étudier des choses qui sont très intéressantes
et c'est bien, ça satisfait
les demandes intellectuelles que nous avons.
Mais ici nous trouvons
la satisfaction de toutes les demandes
les plus profondes de l'âme humaine.
non seulement la sagesse des dieux
et toutes les vertus des dieux,
sa bonté, son amour,
les demandes relationnelles,
les demandes des significations des vies.
Toute la réponse à nos demandes les plus profondes
sont trouvées
dans la révélation des dieux
par ces mystères.
Donc voilà pourquoi on a trouvé bon
de prendre du temps
et de rester dans la considération de ces passages
pendant plusieurs dimanches
en considérant plusieurs aspects
de ces mystères.
Ces mystères,
il est central
pour l'évangile,
pour les buts des dieux
dans l'histoire
et à travers l'histoire.
Ici nous sommes devant les centres
de la raison d'être de l'histoire.
Si Dieu à travers la création
et surtout à travers la rédemption
a décidé de révéler
ou dévoiler sa gloire
de manière suprême,
au centre
c'est l'œuvre du Christ
et l'identité du Christ
qui est composée
par des faits historiques incontestables
et qui a réussi
non seulement à révéler la gloire des dieux
mais à la rendre accessible
à ceux qui sont en lui par la foi.
Et bien sûr que comme nous
qui sommes des chrétiens
ou ceux qui deviennent chrétiens
trouvent dans l'évangile
leur identité
leur plus sublime
la meilleure version
de nous-mêmes
qu'on aurait pu imaginer
mais ne sera pas trouvée
avec les résolutions
des fonds d'année
ou des nouvelles
qui se portent vers
la réussite professionnelle,
l'ascension sociale
ou plus d'éducation formelle.
Elles se trouvent
pour plus que ces choses
puissent être considérées
comme bonnes, si bien filtrées
bien sûr.
Ici nous sommes devant
une chose qui concerne
tous les chrétiens
peu importe
quelles soient leurs conditions
de vie,
leur niveau d'instruction,
leur position sociale
et qui au même temps
définit
la source
de sa joie
suprême
et la signification
de sa vie.
Dans ces passages
Paul est en train d'écrire
à Timothée
en parlant à propos
de l'identité
de l'Église,
c'est que nous sommes
en tant qu'individus
habitation des dieux
mais particulièrement
en tant qu'Église
lorsqu'on est rassemblés.
Donc il parle
du fait
que nous sommes
la maison des dieux,
c'est-à-dire
habitation des dieux,
manifestation des dieux
en chair quelque part
à travers nos vies.
Nous sommes
la maison
de Dieu vivant.
Donc pour que la foi
soit considérée
comme authentique
et vraie chez nous,
c'est quelque chose
que personne ne peut cacher.
Si Dieu habite
chez chacun d'entre nous,
c'est impossible
de cacher Dieu.
Les dieux vivants.
Et l'Église
n'est pas que la maison
de Dieu vivant,
elle est la colonne
et l'appui
de la vérité.
C'est-à-dire
elle est là
pour que la vérité
soit trouvée dedans,
singulière
soit préservée,
pour que cette vérité
absolue,
bien sûr,
soit retrouvée,
pour défendre,
mettre en évidence,
défendre,
proclamer.
Et c'est par
la préservation
de la vérité,
par la proclamation
par la célébration
de la vérité,
avec la vérité
qui est
la manifestation
de Dieu vivant
entre nous,
la maison des dieux,
que l'Église
va comprendre
son identité
et sa fonction.
Notre fonction
et notre identité
est liée
à la réalité
d'un Dieu
qui habite en nous,
qui doit être vue
et perçue
par ceux
qui sont
autour de nous,
mais nous avons
particulièrement
une identité
communautaire.
Dans le Nouveau Testament,
c'est complètement
étranger
la conception
qu'on a trouvée
aujourd'hui
avec plein de déceptions
avec des mauvaises églises,
un mouvement
des chrétiens
sans église.
Je vous défie
à trouver
dans l'Ancien Testament
les croyances
en église,
les définir
même en chrétien
sans que son identité
soit liée
à la notion
d'église.
Et donc,
c'est lui
qui a été manifesté,
pardon,
la maison
de Dieu vivant,
colonne et appui
de la vérité
et là,
on pourrait se demander
mais c'est quoi
la vérité ?
Et donc,
tout de suite,
sans contredire
les mystères
de la piété
à grand,
c'est-à-dire
incontestablement
les mystères
qui rendent possible
que l'église
soit ce qu'elle est,
que les croyants
exercent la fonction
qu'ils ont été créés
par Dieu
pour exercer
leur signification
est liée
à cette vérité
singulière
qui nous est présentée
par l'apôtre Paul
par cette déclaration
confessionnelle
composée
des six sentences.
Donc,
la vérité,
avant tout,
c'est une personne,
c'est lui
qui a été manifesté
en chair,
c'est le fils
des dieux,
la deuxième personne
de la Trinité
qui a été manifesté
en chair.
Et donc,
c'est les mystères
les plus glorieux
qui concernent
nos vies,
notre identité,
la raison d'être,
notre fonction.
Et c'est pour ça
que,
pour nous,
notre résolution,
c'est de comprendre
qu'il en fasse
biblique,
à nouveau,
pour grandir
en maturité
ou pour que l'entrée
dans les royaumes
des cieux
nous soit
pleinement accordée
ou pour que notre
expérience spirituelle
soit de plus en plus
glorieuse,
que notre joie
soit de plus en plus
approfondie,
qu'on arrête
de vivre
ce très mauvais
témoignage
de notre génération
qu'Elloy Jones
appelait la plus
grande contradiction
entre deux termes
qui ne pouvaient
jamais être
vus ensemble.
Les chrétiens
dépressifs.
Et l'une des plus
grandes raisons
pour laquelle
un chrétien
devient dépressif,
c'est car
on nous a déviés
du fait que
les mieux
des dieux
aient déjà
venu
pour être
dans cette dynamique
d'attendre
quelque chose
de plus
que Dieu lui-même
dans nos vies.
Les mystères
les plus glorieux
sont ici
devant nos yeux
et la maturité
chrétienne
n'est pas
de progresser
dans la découverte
des nouveaux mystères
ou de la prospérité
temporelle.
Comme Jude
les appelle
ces faux prophètes
de nouer
sans eau.
il vous dévie
vos yeux
de ce que vous avez
déjà reçu
qui est le plus
glorieux
à propos de vos vies
et il fixe
vos égards
dans les biens
temporels
que Dieu peut
ou peut
n'est pas
vous donner
dans cette vie.
Car il vous a
tout donné
déjà.
Il est lorsque
au mérité
rien.
Donc voici
la conception
biblique
des croissances
en maturité
et expérience
lorsque Dieu
nous enseigne
par sa parole
que nous devons
grandir
en connaissance
et en expérience
avec la compréhension
progressive
de l'amour
de Dieu.
Quelle est la largeur,
la hauteur,
la profondeur ?
On est en train
de nous concentrer
sur ce qui est central
et de nous approfondir
et de persévérer
à connaître
le Seigneur
et pas d'aller
ailleurs
mais garder
nos égards
fixés
sur ces mystères
révélés.
donc ce que nous
trouvons ici
c'est que nous
devons porter
bien sûr
par ces passages
attendez-nous
et nous enseignent
c'est que nous
devons avant tout
croire fermement
dans ces mystères
révélés
que nous devons
déclarer
inflexiblement
que ces faits
sont incontestables
et nous devons
porter notre
propre contribution
d'évidence
attention
lorsqu'il
l'église
croit fermement
lorsqu'il l'église
déclare
de manière
inflexible
les faits
historiques
qui composent
notre foi
et particulièrement
comme il s'agit
d'un chant
lorsqu'il l'église
croit fermement
déclare inflexiblement
et lorsqu'il
adore
rempli d'affection
lorsqu'il
chante
ces mystères
et cette vérité
l'église
elle porte
sa contribution
dans sa génération
d'une évidence
incontestable
que Dieu
les fils
s'est manifesté
que Dieu
est entre nous
montrez-moi
l'orateur
les plus compétents
les docteurs
les plus cultivés
dans un environnement
où
la vérité
n'est pas chantée
de manière authentique
et il nous manquera
une évidence
de la présence
des dieux
entre nous
montrez-moi
une église
qui chante
très fort
qui a les mieux
apparates
!
les mieux
apparets musicaux
jeu des lumières
beaucoup
d'émotions
mais donc
ce qui est chanté
n'est pas
la vérité biblique
et c'est
ça nous manque
l'évidence
incontestable
de la présence
des dieux
entre nous
Dieu est là
où
l'esprit
et la vérité
sont ensemble
où la théologie
la lumière
et les feux
qui chauffent
nos cœurs
sont ensemble
voilà pourquoi
c'est une déclaration
confessionnelle
mais c'est aussi
un chant confessionnel
et l'église
doit donc
chanter
pour grandir
en adoration
nous devons grandir
en connaissance
de ce que la Bible
nous a révélé
et notre objectif
par ce texte
c'est de raviver
notre piété
et nous allons
raviver
notre piété
par la contemplation
la déclaration
et la célébration
de l'oeuvre complète
du Christ
qui s'est manifesté
en chair
donc ces textes
ils nous aident
par la concision
des facettes
les plus importantes
qui concernent
ces mystères révélés
il y a
six facettes
nous avons déjà
considéré cinq
et nous allons
considérer aujourd'hui
la sixième
et la vérité centrale
pour nous
c'est qu'à fin
de raviver
notre piété
nous devons
contempler
déclarer
et célébrer
six choses
la première
l'incontestable
manifestation
en chair
de la douzième
personne
de la sainte
de la trinité
donc la première
chose
qu'on doit
déclarer
de manière
croire
et déclarer
de manière
irréductible
c'est que
le fils des dieux
la douzième
personne
de la trinité
a pris
littéralement
à la forme humaine
qu'il était
100% dieux
100% homme
sans séparation
et sans mixture
un mystère
qui reste un mystère
à plusieurs niveaux
pour nous
mais qui en termes
de révélation
est incontestable
et c'est aussi
une nécessité absolue
pour nous
si nous avons
les moindres espoirs
d'être sauvés
car on avait besoin
d'un médiateur
entre Dieu et les hommes
!
Dieu le Père
a attesté
qu'il est Christ
incarné
était le fils
des dieux
Dieu les fils
lui-même
incarné
a réclamé aussi
qu'il était
fils des dieux
à plusieurs reprises
et nous avons vu
plusieurs preuves
bibliques
et historiques
à propos de l'incarnation
du fils des dieux
et particulièrement
chacune de ces facettes
est liée
à la résurrection
du Christ
donc
la Bible
présente
que l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles
le Christ
n'est pas resté
dans la mort
c'est car
étant l'auteur
de la vie
il ne pourrait pas
être retenu
par la mort
donc sa résurrection
atteste aussi
du fait
que c'est lui
qui a été incarné
qui était mort
qui a ressuscité
des fils des dieux
le deuxième facette
qu'on a considéré
c'est qu'il pourra
vivre notre piété
nous devons contempler
déclarer
et célébrer
l'incontestable
révendication
du Saint-Esprit
à propos
de l'incarnation
messianique
du fils des dieux
donc que les fils
des dieux
soient devenus
hommes
pour accomplir
son oeuvre
des saluts
des rédemptions
messianiques
que celui
qui était incarné
en train de faire
cette oeuvre
que Jésus Christ
des nazarènes
était vraiment
le fils des dieux
c'était la revendication
du Saint-Esprit
partout dans son ministère
de manière visible
externe
toutes les personnes
de cette génération
a vu des preuves
incontestables
qu'il était
le vrai messie
le fils des dieux
mais c'était surtout aussi
par sa résurrection
car Paul en revendant
va nous dire
que le Saint-Esprit
a déclaré
ou revendiqué
Jésus
comme fils des dieux
avec puissance
en les ressuscitant
entre les morts
la troisième facette
c'est que nous devons
croire fermement
contempler
déclarer
et chanter
ou plutôt
joindre les anges
dans leur
incontestable témoignage
à propos
de l'incarnation
messianique
du fils des dieux
donc les anges
la Bible nous dit clairement
il a été
manifesté en chair
justifié par l'esprit
vu des anges
et ici c'est
cette vision
en termes
des témoignages
les anges ont rendu
témoignage
que les christs
étaient les vrais messie
les fils des dieux
dans toutes les étapes
de son ministère
depuis sa naissance
mais particulièrement
c'est au moment de la
ressurrection
et au moment de l'élévation
du Christ
à la gloire
où nous avons
comment les anges
ont pris
une fonction particulière
en tant que témoins
on a considéré
l'importance
et la fiabilité
du témoignage
des anges
la quatrième facette
c'est que nous devons
contempler
déclarer
célébrer
la proclamation
!
surnaturelle
de l'évangile
aux païens
comme preuve incontestable
de l'incarnation
messianique
du fils des dieux
donc là
les textes
il nous dit
il a été prêché
aux gentils
là c'est la proclamation
de l'évangile
à toutes les nations
et pourquoi
on a dit
une proclamation
surnaturelle
c'est car
chacune de ces facettes
n'est pas en train
de nous donner
tout simplement
un ordre chronologique
des faits
elle est en train
de nous montrer
comment
cette oeuvre
complète
et inséparable
pointe vers le fait
qu'il est Christ
aujourd'hui
assis sur son trône
donc ces mêmes disciples
qui avant la résurrection
et l'élévation du Christ
avant la pentecôte
la descente au Saint-Esprit
ont tremblé
devant la menace
la persécution
ces mêmes disciples
qui à plusieurs reprises
ont démontré
comme devant
la forme samaritaine
une espèce
de discrimination
envers certains peuples
ces mêmes disciples
qui étaient
portés
par l'influence
des judaïsants
d'un Israël
nationaliste
à se sentir mieux
que les autres
ce sont les mêmes
disciples
qui après la résurrection
l'ascension
et la descente
du Saint-Esprit
sont en train
de donner leur vie
pour prêcher
aux païens
à toutes les nations
sous menace
et sous persécution
et donc
cette proclamation
courageuse
héraldique
qui devrait
et qui doit
rester toujours
avec nous
dans notre génération
est une preuve
incontestable
du fait
qui est celui
qui a été mort
et ressuscité
qui l'est dans la gloire
et qui l'exhorte
à travers nous
à travers l'évangélisation
de l'Église
de toutes les nations
une autre preuve
incontestable
du fait
qu'il est fils
des dieux
à incarner
et accomplir son œuvre
c'est
la profondeur
et la largeur
de la foi
des convertis
il non seulement
a été prêché
contre les circonstances
humaines
de manière surnaturelle
mais il a été cru
dans un monde
qui respirait
la persécution
où les convertis
n'avaient rien
à gagner
en termes sociaux
et tout à perdre
y compris leur vie
et là
où l'Église
proclamait
avec plus de courage
sans être
très préoccupée
avec la contextualisation
sans être
très préoccupée
avec des jeux
politiques
ou langages
qui cherchent
à éviter
les conflits
culturels
c'est notamment
là où
les principaux
prédicateurs
sont mis à mort
et comme a dit
Tertullian
les saints
des martyrs
et la sémence
de l'Église
c'est là où l'Église
elle est plus grandie
proclamation
franche
frontale
confrontative
héraldique
remplie
de son esprit
remplie d'onction
remplie des certitudes
des fois
en faisant confiance
au fait
que c'est lui
qui était ressuscité
et qui occupait
les troncs célestes
avait promis
qu'il avait
toute l'autorité
devant toutes les nations
sur les ciels
et sur la terre
qui pourrait empêcher
qu'une Église fidèle
avance et grandisse
c'était pas
par des stratégies
humaines
que cela avait lieu
c'était malgré
la persécution
et la mort
des hommes de Dieu
et donc c'est une preuve
incontestable
qu'un tel évangile
soit si répandu
dans les premiers siècles
en ayant commencé
de manière apparemment
très fragile
du point de vue naturel
à largeur
c'est-à-dire
presque toutes les nations
ont été touchées
par l'expansion
de l'Évangile
et la foi
de ces personnes converties
était ferme
à point
de risquer
leur propre vie
donc la logique ici
elle est très intéressante
et très claire
on est en train de voir
de quelle manière
Dieu a donné
des preuves
incontestables
que les dieux
tout-puissants
aient rentré
dans ces mondes
corrompus
réfrataires à Dieu
privés de la gloire
des dieux
et qu'il a fait
avancer
de manière irrésistible
son royaume
en donnant des preuves
que c'est lui
qui s'est livré
lui-même à mort
les christs
étaient ressuscités
qu'il était assis
sous son train de gloire
et que l'Église
allait avancer
c'est la confession
de l'Église
nous ne pouvons pas
reconnaître
comme vrai chrétien
une personne
qui s'est dit
majoritairement chrétienne
je pourrais être d'accord
avec quatre points
et là je ne parle pas
des cinq points
du calvinisme
je parle de ces six
de ces six sentences
qui sont devant nous
des personnes
qui ont des doutes
par rapport
à la double nature
du Christ
Dieu et homme
qui ont des doutes
par rapport
à la manière
dont Christ a été
manifesté en chair
d'une naissance virginale
pour qu'il ne soit pas
corrompu par les péchés
doutes par rapport
à la résurrection
littérale du Christ
ou de son œuvre
messianique
le Christ à la croix
n'est pas
un bon exemple
de l'altruisme
et de comment répondre
à la violence
politique
non il était là
en train de souffrir
de manière littérale
l'enfer
qui a été condensé
déversé sur lui
qui devrait retomber
sur nous
et tout ce qui devrait
qui serait sauvé
et qui a été dévié
de nous
c'est juste
au l'air de Dieu
et qui allait tomber
sur Christ
pour expier
notre culpabilité
et nos fautes
donc si on a des doutes
par rapport
à ces faits historiques
incontestables
que surtout Dieu lui-même
s'est occupé
des données
des preuves incontestables
directement par Dieu
les Pères
par Dieu le Fils
par les anges
par les Saint-Esprit
à travers l'Église
car c'est lui qui pourvoit
la fermeté de la foi
qui rend un bon témoignage
à travers l'expansion
de l'Église légitime
car c'est possible
que ceux qui utilisent
les titres chrétiens
ou Église
soient des apostates
soient faux
soient des sectes
car ils ne croient pas
à tous ces points
ils ne prêchent pas
et voilà pourquoi
on a l'impression
que certaines Églises
sont mortes
c'est impossible
qu'une vraie Église
soit morte
elle est morte
à partir du moment
où elle est corrompue
à propos de ses convictions
où les personnes
qui la composent
ne sont pas vraiment converties
car les vrais chrétiens
sont habitation des dieux
et donc toutes ces choses
portent leur contribution
à ce sixième aspect
cette sixième facette
afin de raviver notre piété
nous devons contempler
déclarer
et célébrer surtout
l'incontestable élévation
du Fils des dieux
manifesté en chair
et ressuscité à la gloire
tout est lié
à cette notion
d'une seule vérité
un seul mystère
sublime
un ensemble
à nouveau
chronologiquement
on peut voir
la logique
manifesté en chair
il a été
justifié
justifié par l'esprit
vu des anges
précieux gentils
cru dans le monde
élevé dans la gloire
dans un certain sens
toutes ces choses
se sont accomplies
pendant les ministères
de la terre du Christ
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
élevé dans la gloire
mais non seulement
nous sommes devant
une chronologie
mais plutôt
une culmination
qui justifie pour toujours
la continuité
du succès
que Christ a conquis
à la croix
par sa mort
et sa résurrection
c'est particulièrement
à partir du moment
il est élevé
dans la gloire
qu'il a déclenché
voilà pourquoi
la nouvelle alliance
elle n'est pas vécue
envers une attente
de la restauration
d'un sabbat
d'une œuvre
qui un jour
a été complète
mais à cause
de notre faute
on a remis Dieu
au travail
et on est encore
dans l'attente
que Dieu
nous apporte
les réponses
c'était l'attente
de l'Ancien Testament
dans le Nouveau Testament
c'est différent
les royaumes
des dieux
avancent
avec l'engagement
du peuple des dieux
mais la certitude
l'assurance
quelque part
du point de vue divin
la facilité
avec laquelle
les royaumes des dieux
avancent
même si notre perception
parfois car nos yeux
ne sont pas
au bon endroit
c'est les contraires
c'est que Christ
a déclenché à la croix
c'est car il a vécu
le vrai sabbat
Père
tout est accompli
et il est
assis
sur son tronc
lorsqu'il est élevé
c'est à dire
d'être assis
signifie
oeuvre complète
et pourquoi
il est appelé
les vrais sabbats
car
même si
on pense à trois jours
après lesquels
il serait ressuscité
il y a seulement
un jour
qu'il a vraiment
reposé
complètement
les sabbats
il a accompli
la signification
du sabbat
pour à partir
de la ressuruction
déclencher
la nouvelle alliance
et quelque chose
glorieuse
la nouvelle alliance
qui est fondée
et centrée
sur ces jours
car cette élévation
du Christ
elle va passer
non seulement
à être la culmination
de son oeuvre
chronologique
sur terre
mais la position
fixée
constante
d'une fois
pour toutes
en ayant accompli
d'intercesseurs
irrésistibles
car toutes les choses
qu'il est
Christ a payé
par son oeuvre
son intercession
n'est pas
un plaidoyer
un supplice
devant Dieu
c'est tout simplement
une question
de timing
les moments
où Christ
trouve bon
appliquer
son oeuvre
à un individu
qui va se convertir
il intercède au Père
basé sur une oeuvre
parfaite et complète
il n'est jamais
en train d'intercéder
contrairement à la volonté
de Dieu
car les plans
étaient les plans
de Dieu
s'il est Père
mais à partir
du moment
où les Christ
basés sur son oeuvre
parfaite
en tant que notre
substitut
intercède
pour rendre
ses enfants
il est tout simplement
en train de réclamer
un droit
qu'il a conquis
par son oeuvre
parfaite
c'est impossible
de trouver résistance
devant les trônes
de la grâce
de Dieu
si nous sommes
en Christ
vous comprenez
un peu mieux
toute autorité
m'a été donnée
toutes les choses
que vous demanderez
en mon nom
c'est-à-dire
un accord
avec ma réputation
bien sûr
c'est pas pour sponsoriser
vos idolâtries personnelles
mais pensez que vous pouvez
mettre Dieu
contre les murs
et exiger
de Dieu quelque chose
par ce type
des prières
qui ne semblent plus
plus de la blasphème
contre Dieu
et contre tout
ce que la vie
nous enseigne
à propos de la prière
mais c'est de
nous accorder
aux priorités du Christ
à propos de nos vies
à propos de notre salut
de notre sanctification
et joindre
cette intercession
que Christ
est en train de faire
pour nous
là où il est assis
aujourd'hui
là où c'est irrésistible
au Père
de dire
Amen
à toutes les choses
que le Christ
veut
souplier
pour son peuple
ou intercéder
et donc nous voyons
comment en fait
la progression
de l'Église
nous voyons comment
la répandue de la foi
elle ne peut jamais
dépendre
tout simplement
de nos efforts
de nos stratégies
et ça a des implications
énormes
par rapport au niveau
des corruptions
par exemple
des visions missionnaires
qu'on a de nos jours
des fois on a l'impression
qu'à moins qu'on ne devienne
expert
dans la France post-moderne
en toute philosophie
on n'aurait pas
la capacité
de prêcher l'Évangile
ou
on se sent sous pression
de croire
à une interprétation
malabariste
de Genèse
car on est sous la pression
des soi-disant
découvertes scientifiques
ou on pense
qu'il faut connaître
être des experts
de toutes les cultures
pour
prêcher les mêmes
Évangiles
aux mêmes êtres
humains
peu importe
où ils sont trouvés
car la Bible
se dirige
aux problèmes
radicaux
de tout être humain
et Dieu
est celui
qui appelle
finalement
et qui a la capacité
de sommer
à la répentance
à travers
la fidélité
de notre prédication
Christ est assis
sur son trône
pour nous
l'image
comme on vous a dit
les dimanches derniers
du Christ
qui ont des vrais
les plus gardés
c'est du Christ
qui accomplit
son œuvre parfaite
notre croix
différente des catholiques
n'est pas une croix
qui a les Christ
sacrifiés
c'est une croix vide
pour diriger
nos égards
au Christ victorieux
Christus Victor
c'est lui
qui nous a dit
de manière très claire
en indiquant
le fait
qu'il allait monter
au ciel
que toute autorité
lui a été donnée
qui nous a dit
que les portes
de l'enfer
ne pouvaient pas
c'est cette
interpretation
intéressante
car les portes
de l'enfer
ne peuvent pas
prévaloir
contre l'avancement
de l'église
la vision
des dieux
à propos de l'église
c'est pas
un ghetto
dans ses tranches
avec peur
de dire la vérité
l'église
par la perspective
du Christ
c'est celle
qui avance
et aucun empire
de ténèbres
ne peut résister
à l'avancement
de l'église
nous pouvons être
considérés
comme peu nombreux
dans chaque génération
mais si
nos égards
sont fixés
dans celui
qui a les contrôles
de toutes les choses
et qui nous a assurés
que l'église
va avancer
nous allons participer
avec plus d'efficacité
à l'avancement
de l'église
donc
il faut qu'on analyse
trois aspects
de cette déclaration
la première
c'est l'aspect
incontestable
du fait
qu'il a été élevé
dans la gloire
le Christ
a été élevé
dans la gloire
et ça
nous est présenté
comme un fait
incontestable
de quelle manière
ces faits incontestables
est attestés
la première manière
c'est par
les enseignements
du Christ lui-même
donc si on va vers
par exemple
les prières
sacerdotales
du Christ
si on va vers
certains passages
comme celui des gens
je vous lis
à partir de verset 23
l'heure est venue
où les fils de l'homme
doivent être
glorifiés
et là
la Bible est en train
de nous enseigner
quelque part
la certitude
du fait
qu'il est Christ
qui est venu
et qui est incarné
pour accomplir sa mission
il savait très bien
que sa mission
ne serait complète
qu'à partir du moment
en ayant accompli
ce qu'il fallait
en tant que notre représentant
humain
il revient à la gloire
pour intercéder pour nous
il dit
en vérité
je vous l'ai dit
si les grands des blés
les tombent en terre
et ne meurent
ils ne meurent
seuls
mais s'ils meurent
ils portent beaucoup de fruits
ils devraient être glorifiés
avec la conscience
qu'ils seraient glorifiés
par sa mort
et ressurrections
j'ai un 17
il dit
père
le temps
il dit
glorifie ton fils
afin que ton fils
te glorifie
comme tu lui as donné
pouvoir sur toute chair
afin qu'il donne
la vie éternelle
à tous ceux
qui lui sont donnés
que tu lui as donné
or la vie éternelle
c'est qu'il te connaisse
toi le seul vrai Dieu
et celui qui tu as envoyé
Jésus Christ
j'ai été glorifié sur terre
j'ai achevé l'oeuvre
que tu m'as donné
à faire
et maintenant
père glorifie-moi
près de toi
dès la gloire
que j'avais près de toi
avant que le monde fût
vous voyez
l'impossibilité
de ne pas identifier ici
une description du Christ
lui-même
comme préexistant
comme Dieu lui-même
comme douzième
personne de la Trinité
et conscience
qu'en étant incarné
manifesté en chair
il devrait accomplir
cette oeuvre terrestre
afin de revenir
là où il avait
la gloire avec Dieu
avant la fondation
du monde
je pourrais
vous citer
d'autres passages
de la bouche
du Christ lui-même
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
cette transition
après sa résurrection
Luc 24
où il dit
à ses disciples
dans les chiens
de Maïs
ne fallait-il pas
c'était une nécessité
que les Messies
que les Christ
souffrent ces choses
et qu'il entra
dans sa gloire
donc c'est une nécessité
que cette oeuvre
inséparable
et complète
ait lieu
qu'il soit
celui
qui vit la vie parfaite
à notre place
dans la chair humaine
pour nous représenter
pour être les nouveaux
là-dedans
et qu'il soit
mort
qu'il souffre
les choses
qu'il soit
ressuscité
et le plus important
par rapport
à sa résurrection
est sa glorification
mais pour qu'on ait
aucun doute
à propos
de sa résurrection
il nous a donné
plein d'épreuves
incontestables
en restant
quelques temps
entre les disciples
où 500 personnes
comme la lettre
des Corinthiens
nous affirme
a pu passer du temps
avec Christ
après sa résurrection
mais le plus important
ici
c'est qu'il souffre
afin d'entrer
dans sa gloire
c'est intéressant
aussi de remarquer
de quelle manière
généreuse
et visible
par la transfiguration
marque 9
les Christ
a fait
en prénonce
une avant-première
si on peut dire
comme ça
de sa glorification
du fait
qu'il serait
inévitablement
élevé dans la gloire
Jésus Christ
a dit à ses disciples
en vérité
je vous l'ai dit
il y en a quelques-uns
ici
qui ne passeront pas
de cette vie
sans avoir vu
le royaume de Dieu
venir avec puissance
la descente
du royaume de Dieu
manifestée
avec puissance
connexion du texte
six jours après
Jésus prit avec lui
Pierre
Jacques
et Jean
et il les conduisit
à l'écart
sur une autre montagne
où ils furent témoins
de la transfiguration
de Jésus
ses vêtements
dévorent éclatants
d'une blancheur
telle
qu'aucun foulon
sur terre
ne saurait rendre
une blancheur
pareille
et l'île
leur apparu
avec Moïse
et ils s'entraîtaient
avec Jésus
très intéressant
et l'île
qui était
l'un des plus importants
types du Christ
par rapport
à toutes les puissances
et miracles
qu'il a opérés
sous l'onction
de son esprit
ce qui confirme
c'est que les Christ
devraient
aussi représenter
de manière
sublime
archétype
et Moïse
et les textes publiques
nous enseignent
que la discussion
ici c'était
les choses
que les Christ
devraient souffrir
quel est le lien
important pour nous
pratique
c'est que Christ
en tant qu'homme
on voit
Jetsémonie
car il devrait
accomplir cette oeuvre
en tant qu'homme
à notre place
et dans les mystères
de sa nature humaine
il était hésitant
il savait mieux
que personne
les choses
qui devraient
souffrir pour nous
nous avons
la moindre idée
de combien
infinie
est la pureté
et la sainteté
des dieux
la Bible
nous montre
quelques illustrations
comme les feux
que personne
ne peut s'approcher
car déjà
on n'a pas
la même nature
que Dieu
donc même
les anges
qui sont purs
doivent couvrir
leur visage
mais le feu
qui surtout
purifie
toute impureté
et là
c'est un problème
grave pour nous
donc les moindres
péchés
sont dignes
d'en faire
pas par comparaison
entre nos péchés
c'est par comparaison
entre les moindres
péchés
et la sainteté
infinie
des dieux
c'est pas optionnel
Dieu n'est pas
quantitativement
il est absolument
sans
et la moindre
chute
de la
parfaite
sainteté
c'est déjà
la ténèbre
on n'est pas
devant
des tonalités
de gris
on est soit
la lumière
pleine
ou
les pleines
ténèbres
et donc ici
le Christ
il a
la conscience
de ce qu'il doit
souffrir
à cause
de nos péchés
l'enfer
de chacun
d'entre nous
condensé
la croix
et déversé
sur lui
voilà pourquoi
les personnes
mouraient
ils pourraient
rester vivants
entre 3 jours
par exemple
crucifiés
3, 4, 5 jours
parfois
et le Christ
est mort
en 3 heures
pourquoi
il n'a pas souffert
tout simplement
physiquement
il a souffert
l'enfer
à notre place
et donc
à partir de là
on voit
dans ces passages
qu'il avait
besoin
quelque part
d'être
renforcé
dans ses convictions
en tant qu'être
humain
et de quelle manière
Dieu les pères
va l'encourager
en disant
voici mon fils
bien-aimé
à lui
écouter
et en lui
donnant
en prénonce
de l'assurance
de sa résurrection
et glorification
quelle est la stratégie
de l'apôtre Paul
plus tard
lorsqu'il veut
nous encourager
devant la mort
il va pointer
envers la résurrection
et glorification
de Christ
et va nous dire
tout comme
il était les premiers-nés
et que les corps
s'aimés
de manière corruptible
par la mort
et qu'il est récolté
avec un corps glorifié
c'est car le Christ
a vécu cette réalité
que nous pouvons
avoir la certitude
de cette espérance
et c'est dans la proportion
de cette conviction
que les martyrs
sont partis
vers la mort
en ayant les égards
fixés sur les Christ
ressuscités
dont Étienne
est un exemple
incroyable
car pendant
qu'il est en train
de mourir
il contemple
les fils des dieux
qui assis
sous son trône
et qui s'élèvent
pour contempler
sa souffrance
c'est dès là
qu'il tire son assurance
qu'il ressuscite aussi
et qu'il serait
avec Christ
et donc
Élie leur apparu
avec Moïse
il s'entraînait
avec Jésus
et Pierre
prenant la parole
dit
Rabbi
il est bon
que nous sois ici
des ressources
trois tentes
une pour toi
une pour Moïse
et une pour Élie
car il ne savait dire
qu'ils étaient tous
saisis des frères
et une nouée
vent les couvrir
et de la nuit
sortit une voix
qui dit
celui-ci est mon fils
bien-aimé
écoutez-le
aussitôt ils regardèrent
autour d'eux
et ils ne virent plus
que Jésus seul
avec eux
l'importance
des Moïse
des lits
très intéressant
pour Pierre
et la seule chose
qui emporte à la fin
c'est Christ seul
nous voyons aussi
les témoignages
oculaires
de l'ascension
du Christ
qui la rend aussi
incontestable
et là on voit
un acte 1
du verset 9
à 11
après qu'il leur dit
c'est là
il fut élevé
pendant qu'il regardait
et une nouée
les cachait à leurs yeux
et comme ils avaient
leurs yeux
fixés vers les ciels
pendant
qu'il s'en allait
voici deux hommes
en vêtements blancs
se présentèrent à eux
et dire
homme galiléant
pourquoi vous arrêtez-vous
à regarder au ciel
c'est Jésus
qui a été enlevé
d'avec vous au ciel
viendra
dès là
de la manière
que vous l'avez vu
aller au ciel
j'ai déjà évoqué
donc
non seulement
tous ces disciples
qui étaient réunis
qui étaient en train
de voir le Christ
élever la gloire
mais nous voyons aussi
l'expérience d'Étienne
qui l'a vu
qui par une vision
a vu Christ
assis sur son trône
glorifié
et même Paul
car le Christ
quand même
après sa résurrection
et après sa glorification
a reçu la visite
du Christ glorifié
c'est la seule chose
qu'il peut expliquer
la conversion
d'un homme
qui était en pleine force
contraire
à l'Église
et donc
c'est incontestable
tout simplement
le premier aspect
qu'il écrit
ça a été glorifié
mais il y a un autre aspect
intéressant
qui doit attester
cette réalité
et c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'expérience
de l'Église
c'est-à-dire
nous
et c'est ça
pour nous
la pertinence principale
de réfléchir à ce texte
nous sommes
la continuité
de ce ministère
du Christ
assis sur son trône
et il est en train
d'éprouver
le fait
qu'il est glorifié
assis sur son trône
par la manière
dont l'Église
est en train
de rendre témoignage
de ces faits
Colossiens chapitre 1
va nous dire
à eux
Dieu a voulu faire connaître
quelle est la glorieuse richesse
de ces mystères
parmi les païens
à savoir
Christ en vous
l'espérance
de la gloire
si notre foi
est ancrée
dans un Christ
assis sur un trône
et comme la Bible nous dit
notre vie
est cachée en Christ
dans les lieux célestes
par expérience
tous les chrétiens
vont manifester
dans cette vie
la vie du Christ
en nous
envers les païens
et donc il y a
un aspect très expérimental
dans notre foi
qui est la manifestation
des dieux
à travers nous
en nous
et à travers nous
les Christ
qui habitent en nous
de manière littérale
même si spirituelle
et la manière
dont on va rendre témoignage
à ceux qui nous entourent
à notre génération
qui tous peuvent avoir
l'espérance
des gloires
car la gloire céleste
est déjà en train
de se manifester
à travers nous
par la foi
car Christ
habite en nous
et donc il y a un aspect
tellement expérimental
dans la foi chrétienne
et voilà pourquoi
ça s'exprime
en termes de vie pieuse
en termes des chants
Jean
en Jean chapitre 14
voici ce qu'il dit
le Seigneur
et moi je prierai
les Pères
et il vous donnera
un autre consolateur
afin qu'il demeure
éternellement avec vous
l'esprit de vérité
que le monde
ne peut recevoir
parce qu'il ne voit point
et ne les connaît point
mais vous
vous les connaissez
car il demeure avec vous
et il sera avec vous
et donc
l'aspect expérimental
de la foi chrétienne
ne peut pas manquer
dans un chrétien authentique
conscience
de l'habitation
de la troisième
personne de la Trinité
en moi
j'ai beau été
sous l'influence
de mes parents
lorsqu'ils essayaient
de partager l'évangile
j'ai beau été
sous l'influence
de mes amis chrétiens
lorsqu'ils essayaient
de me partager l'évangile
Paul
il était en train
d'étudier la Bible
de manière fanatique
mais il était
un spécialiste
des écritures
et comment il va
expliquer son salut
lorsqu'il a plu
à celui
qui m'avait séparé
dès l'évangile
de ma mère
de révéler son fils
en moi
donc les Christ
glorifié
à un moment donné
assis sous son trône
lorsqu'il est en train
d'intercéder
il va dire
Seigneur
c'est le moment
de réclamer
la conversion
de David
et c'est ce jour là
où la personne
se convertit
vous comprenez
assis
sur son trône
de gloire
à nous
d'accomplir
la fonction
secondaire
que nous avons
de proclamer
l'évangile
à plusieurs reprises
mais la conversion
de chaque individu
doit être perçue
par lui-même
comme une manifestation
incontestable
d'un Christ
glorifié
qui passe
à gouverner
sa vie
la même chose
doit être comprise
quand on considère
par exemple
les ordonnances
à l'église
la présence
spirituelle
du Christ
entre nous
en tant que communauté
voilà pourquoi
l'apôtre Paul
parle de l'importance
de ne pas
prendre la sainte scène
à la légère
car nous annonçons
par la sainte scène
nous sommes en train
de réclamer
publiquement
les faits
que nous sommes
les corps du Christ
les corps
en qui le Christ
habite
et nous sommes là
pour annoncer
la mort du Christ
jusqu'à ce qu'il vient
c'est à dire
il est mort
il a payé nos péchés
nous sommes réconciliés
avec Dieu
mais il vient
et il vient
et de quelle manière
nous annonçons
qu'il vient
c'est car
dès sa position
des trônes de gloire
il est en train
de transformer
nos vies
en nouveauté
des vies
progressant
en santé
il est vivant
à travers nous
nous annonçons
qu'il est mort
dans le passé
mais qu'il est vivant
il est vivant
à travers l'église
qui progresse
en santé
et la même chose
se passe
au moment du baptême
car nous sommes baptisés
en son nom
pour manifester
sa réputation
sa vie
les noms
des dieux
signifient
non seulement
sa réputation
mais la manière
de l'invoquer
la manière
dont il se manifeste
à travers l'église
et donc voilà
pourquoi
nous pouvons
considérer
comme incontestable
cette glorification
du Christ
l'auteur d'Hébreu
nous montre
non seulement
et c'est le deuxième aspect
que ces choses
sont incontestables
cette glorification
du Christ
mais qu'elle était
nécessaire
et efficace
et donc
sa thèse
dans les chapitres
depuis les chapitres 1
les chapitres 4
les 7
les 9
les 10
c'est de démontrer
les Christ
comme les suprêmes
sacrificateurs
j'ai pas le temps
de lire tous les textes
mais l'idée
c'est qu'on comprenne
l'absolue nécessité
qui est celui
qui a été mort
et ressuscité
ne reste pas sur terre
et qui l'accomplisse
sa gouvernance
avec toute autorité
depuis
les trônes
de l'univers
car les sanctuaires
terrestres
étaient une ombre
d'un sanctuaire céleste
et donc
les jugements
cosmiques
de tous les êtres humains
ne se passent pas
à travers
la représentation
du temple d'Israël
du tabernacle
ou de l'église
terrestre
nous pouvons
en tant qu'église
fonctionner comme des ambassades
faire des déclarations
au nom des dieux
mais la réalité
c'est que
tous ces ombres
ont leur accomplissement
parfait
réel
spirituel
avec les Christ
qui est mort
avec un corps humain
littéral
qui est ressuscité
avec un corps humain
littéral
et qui est parti
vers la gloire
avec un corps humain
les mêmes corps
qui ont été sacrifiés
pour être présentés
en tant que sacrifice
devant les pères
qu'est-ce qu'ils faisaient
les sacrificateurs
du temple
prenaient
ces animaux
qui avaient été
substitutivement
sacrifiés
mais la pénalité
que ces animaux
souffraient
n'était pas
la seule partie
du travail
il fallait intercéder
pour appliquer
aux personnes
concernées
son innocence
et son expiation
bien sûr
qu'un animal
n'a pas la capacité
de médier
Dieu et les hommes
!
d'être les médiateurs
entre Dieu et les hommes
donc il fallait
qu'il soit
dans sa personne
les parfaits médiateurs
!
le sacrifice parfait
et les sacrificateurs
parfaits
selon l'ordre
de Mekizadei
qui n'a pas
décommencement
ni fin
d'une fois pour tout
il a sacrifié
et d'une fois pour tout
il est assis
pour intercéder
sur la base
de cette oeuvre
complète
c'était nécessaire
mais c'était pas
que nécessaire
c'est parfaitement
efficace
vous comprenez
si vous plongez
dans ces convictions
c'est fini
manque d'assurance
de salut
la grossière hérésie
de la perte
du salut
c'est de dire
son oeuvre
n'était pas suffisante
anathème
son oeuvre
n'était pas complète
il manque quelque chose
comme font les catholiques
jusqu'aujourd'hui
à chaque Eucharistie
c'est comme s'ils étaient
en train de sacrifier
l'Écrit à nouveau
parfaitement efficace
et ses implications
pour l'évangélisation
sont incroyables
c'est sur cette base
que l'Écrit va dire
avant de partir
pour être glorifié
il va dire aux onze
toute autorité
m'a été donnée
sur les ciels
et sur la terre
allez donc
faites des disciples
de toutes les nations
les défis
des points de vue
humains
c'était incroyable
et l'assurance
du point de vue
spirituel
elle sublime
aucune autorité
désormais
ne peut être restreinte
Dieu n'a jamais perdu
son autorité pleine
sauf que comme
la condamnation
de la race humaine
était similaire
à la condamnation
des satans
à partir du moment
où Dieu
justement a décidé
d'éteindre sa patience
pour développer
les plans de la rédemption
il a toléré aussi
Satan
et jusqu'à ce que
Christ n'avait pas
accompli son oeuvre
parfaite
pour justifier
devant sa propre justice
les droits
de nous bénir
l'accusateur
était toujours
en train de dire
pourquoi
vas-tu les bénir
s'ils sont si rebelles
que moi
et une fois
que Christ a tout
accompli
il n'y a plus
aucune restreinte
l'accusateur
n'a aucune puissance
et les remdes
de Dieu
ne fait qui avancer
et voilà pourquoi
en acte
chapitre 1
nous voyons la même assurance
de la part du Christ
vous recevrez
une puissance
les saints esprits
et vous serrez
mes témoins
c'est pas
vous possiblement
serrez mes témoins
dans toutes
les extrémités
de la terre
Christ ici
n'est pas en train
de parler des probabilités
ou possibilités
il est en train
de faire une déclaration
une description
un constat
le saint esprit
va habiter en vous
et vous serrez
mes témoins
car il va
monter à la gloire
et le troisième
et aspect final
c'est lorsqu'on contemple
par la perspective céleste
et c'est là
on doit accorder
nos affections
car on est en train
de parler de l'importance
des croix fermement
donc des vents
des faits incontestables
on est en train
de considérer
l'importance
de déclarer
avec fidélité
car sans ces choses
il n'y a pas de salut
il n'y a pas d'assurance
du salut
il n'y a pas d'avancement
d'église
mais nous parlons aussi
surtout du fait
que nous devons confesser
croire et déclarer
avec nos affections
profondément touchées
chanter
glorifier Dieu
car c'est là
où se trouve
notre vision
beatifique de Christ
et j'aimerais revenir
à un texte
qui Loïc a lu
plus tôt
et avant
vous rappelez
on va lire
Apocalypse 5
pour conclure
mais juste avant
je vais faire un parallèle
avec l'Epsomme
24 de David
donc ici
nous sommes devant
deux chants
vous êtes avec moi ?
de quelle manière
l'église doit confesser
sa foi
remplie d'affection
d'adoration
en chantant
et donc
l'Epsomme de David
c'était
la liturgie
des chants
communautaires
de l'Ancien Testament
et l'Epsomme 24
il dit le suivant
à l'éternel
la terre
et ce qu'elle renferme
les mondes
et ceux
qui l'habitent
car il l'a fondé
sur les mers
et affermi
sur les fleuves
pardon
et donc là
c'est une description
de toute cette gloire
qui est quelque part
l'extension extérieure
plus accessible à nous
et sa gloire
mais la terre
n'est qu'un petit
adornement
qui pointe
envers la gloire céleste
et donc il dit
qui pourra monter
à la montagne
de l'éternel
qui s'élèvera
jusqu'à son sain lieu
qu'est-ce qui nous vient
à nos esprits
possiblement
l'expérience
de la plus grande
révélation des dieux
avant Christ
les monts Sinai
ces monts tremblants
ces monts
enflammés
où Dieu est descendu
dans une forme
des nouées obscures
où on était devant
l'effrayeur
devant la sainteté des dieux
et en même temps
une anticipation glorieuse
des pouvoirs
communiers avec lui
les dieux transcendants
inaccessibles
sans
et en même temps
en s'effaisant
immanent
mais qui pourra
monter à cette montagne
si ce qui est exigé
est la pureté de vie
et la réponse
pour nous
ceux qui avons la foi
c'est qu'il y a
l'aimant innocent
celui qui a l'aimant innocent
et le coeur pur
celui qui ne livre pas
son âme
aux mensonges
et qui ne jure pas
pour tromper
c'est un rappel
il y a plusieurs aspects
de décalogue
mais ici
l'emphase est plus mise
sur la sincérité
de notre foi
car nous sommes
un parfait
c'est la transparence
la confession
la foi
mais pas que ça
et qui ne jure pas
pour tromper
verset 5
il obtiendra
la bénédiction
de l'éternel
la miséricorde
de Dieu
de son salut
voilà
les partages
de la génération
qu'il invoque
quel est le partage
de ceux qui invoquent Dieu
de ceux qui cherchent
ta face
de Jacob
et donc
une pause
pour communiquer
l'aspect solennel
une pause
pour
penser à l'attention
de cette possibilité
qui par ses qualifications
pourrait se dire
moi
je suis cette personne
basée sur ma pureté
des coeurs
des mains
basée sur
la véracité
de ma vie
l'authenticité
dont j'invoque
le nom de Dieu
pour l'adorer
donc j'ai manifesté
ma vie
qui ma plus grande portion
c'est Dieu lui-même
et donc il est en tension
qui peut monter
dans la sainte montagne
et la réponse
qui a été une prophétie
incroyable
à propos du Christ
porte
les portes
qui sont fermées
pour nous
élevez vos lenteux
élevez-vous
porte éternelle
que les rois des gloires
fassent son entrée
l'élévation du Christ
dans la gloire
qui est ces rois des gloires
l'éternel fort et puissant
l'éternel puissant
dans les combats
porte élevez vos lenteux
élevez les portes
éternelles
que les rois des gloires
de gloire
fassent son entrée
qui donc
est ces rois des gloires
l'éternel des armées
voilà
les rois des gloires
qui peut rentrer
en lisant les pélérants
les voyages des pélérants
avec mes enfants
il y a cette ville
cette cité fort
où personne ne peut rentrer
un seul
était capable
de le faire
c'est lui
qui a ouvert
les schémas
et donc pour conclure
avec Apocalypse 5
cette tension
qui est encore
plus clarifiée
et ici
nous sommes devant
les centres
de l'univers
notre système
on dit que
les systèmes solaires
ce sont les planètes
qui tournent autour
du soleil
mais tout l'univers
tourne autour
de ces trônes
ces trônes des gloires
la vision des gens
et la tension
est la même
et j'ai vu dans la main droite
de celui qui était assis
sur les trônes
un livre
écrit en dedans
et en dehors
scellé par sept sceaux
et j'ai vu un ange puissant
qui criait d'une voix forte
qui est digne
d'ouvrir les livres
et d'en rompre les sceaux
et personne
ni dans les ciels
ni sur la terre
ne pouvait
ouvrir les livres
ni les regarder
et j'ai pleuré beaucoup
parce qu'aucun
aucun n'avait été
trouvé
digne d'ouvrir les livres
ni de les regarder
et l'un des anciens
médis
ne pleure pas
voici
les lions
de la tribu des Judas
assez glorieux
mais devant
les trônes des dieux
et ce qu'on va retrouver
c'est que ces livres
sont les livres
qui donnent
tous les droits
à celui qui gouverne
d'exécuter
sans restriction
son autorité
de dire à chaque
atomes
ce qu'ils doivent faire
et les atomes
doivent dire
Amen
de déclarer
les saluts
de ceux
qui seront sauvés
l'élevage
ou la chute
de toutes les nations
et personne
n'était digne
et surtout
c'est concerné
par ces livres
les livres
et les noms
de ceux
qui seront sauvés
bien sûr
et donc
personne
n'était capable
et j'ai pleuré
beaucoup
les jours
où devant
la crise
de David
on a été
confronté
avec
l'exigence
d'une santé
pour accéder
à la présence
des dieux
est-ce que vous avez
pleuré
été
avec vos affections
d'accord
avec cette vérité
sans répentance
il n'y a pas
la vraie foi
cette crise
accédée
à la présence
des dieux
et l'un des anciens
médicaux
ne pleure pas
voici
les lions
de la tribu
des Judas
et rejetons
David
il a vancu
pour ouvrir
les livres
et les sept sceaux
et donc
on parle d'un lion
et qu'est-ce qu'on voit
et lorsqu'il tourne
son égard
pour voir les lions
qu'est-ce qu'ils trouvent
et j'ai vu
au milieu du trône
et des quatre êtres vivants
ces quatre êtres vivants
qui d'entre les anges
représentent
possiblement
toute l'humanité
et toute la création
glorifiée
représentant l'adoration
de toute la création
rachetée
restaurée
ce sont les êtres
qui ont été créés
avec la capacité
d'être les plus proches
du trône de Dieu
la sensibilité
qu'ils ont
par rapport à la sainteté
de Dieu
par rapport à l'adoration
voici pourquoi
pour l'instant
ils ont même plus
de capacité
que nous
de réjouir
de notre propre salut
et au milieu
des quatre êtres vivants
des anciens
donc les 24 anciens
qui représentent
les douze tribus
de l'Ancien Testament
et l'Église
les apôtres
un agneau
qui semblait
avoir été immolé
vous voyez
les sanctuaires célestes
avec son corps
sacrifié
l'agneau pascal
monte au ciel
et son identité
sera pour toujours
car la gloire
révélée du Christ
la gloire des dieux
révélée en Christ
elle est surtout
centrée par son oeuvre
de rédemption
pour toujours
nous allons nous plonger
davantage et davantage
dans l'adoration
de l'agneau des dieux
son identité
jamais séparée
qui semblait
avoir été immolé
il avait sept cornes
ce qui signifie
autorité
donc sept
les nombres symboliques
des perfections
toute autorité
m'a été donnée
donc il avait
sept cornes
qui sont les sept esprits
des dieux
envoyés
dans toute la terre
et donc
Pentecôte
toute autorité
m'a été donnée
et vous recevrez
le Saint-Esprit
et vous sérémettez-moi
sans réserve
et il vend
et il prie les livres
ah c'est très bon
de qui il a pris
les livres
donc là
c'est pas pour considérer
une résistance
de la part des dieux
la résistance
à prendre les livres
à ouvrir le seau
c'est
la sainteté
absolue des dieux
qui ne peut pas
nous bénir
sans avoir fait
la justification
sans intercession
du suprême sacrificateur
Dieu il veut
nous bénir
c'est lui qui planifie
et les fils
viennent
et qu'est
au fils
et avec toute la joie
les pères
donnent au fils
les livres
ils vendent
avec toute autorité
ils prendent les livres
de la main droite
et c'est lui
qui est assis sur le trône
et quand il prie
les livres
les quatre êtres vivants
et les 24 anciens
se prosternèrent
devant la nuit
chacun d'eux
avait une harpe
et des coupes remplies
des coupes d'or
remplies des parfums
qui sont les prières
des saints
voilà comment nos prières
s'éjoignent
et notre adoration
s'éjoigne
à elle
et ils chantaient
un cantique nouveau
en disant
voici la nouvelle alliance
tu es digne
de prendre les livres
et d'en ouvrir les seaux
car tu as été immolé
et tu as racheté
pour Dieu
des hommes
de toutes tribus
de toutes langues
de tout peuple
de toutes les nations
qui est le seul
qui serait capable
de résister
à la possibilité
du salut des nations
Dieu seul
les dieux tout puissants
les dieux trois façons
à partir du moment
où les fils
a la possibilité
de prendre ses livres
de l'ouvrir
et de décréter
les saluts des nations
personne ne peut empêcher
l'église
qu'on soit fondée
sur les décrets
les déclarations
l'intercession
la victoire
la puissance irrésistible
du Christ
qu'est-ce qui nous rend
timide
à proclamer l'évangile encore
quelle vision
pour être plus glorieuse
que celle-ci
qu'est-ce qu'on est
en train d'attendre
quand on va
des réunions en réunion
en attendant
d'avoir une nouvelle vision
une nouvelle révélation
la révélation sublime
suprême
c'est celle-ci
les mystères dévoilés
les Christ
ingressant
au trône des gloires
en recevant
de la main du Père
les livres
de l'histoire
qui concerne surtout
le salut
de chaque individu chrétien
qui va
se convertir
de toutes les nations
et qu'est-ce qu'il chantait
tu es digne
de prendre les livres
et ouvrir les seaux
les seaux pardon
car tu as été immolé
et tu as racheté
pour Dieu
des hommes de toutes tribules
toutes langues
tout peuple
et toute nation
tu les as faits
rois et prêtres
pour notre Dieu
et ils régneront
sur la terre
donc c'est
je m'excuse
ou je ne m'excuse pas
mais là
on rentre clairement
au moins dans ma position
par rapport
à l'inauguration
du roi des dieux
c'est déjà
la saison
ou la dispensation
au Christ sainte
en dérigne
à travers l'église
qui avance
l'écriv sous son trône
envoie son esprit
il gouverne
sur toutes les choses
il n'y a plus
de nouvelles étapes
les sentences
s'arrêtent ici
mais là
c'est un domaine
dans la théologie
où on peut avoir
des positions différentes
et on va traiter ça
dans une autre occasion
et j'ai regardé
et j'ai tendu
la voix
des nombreux anges
autour du trône
des êtres vivants
et des anciens
leur nombre était
des myriades
des milliers
êtres vivants
et anciens
leur nombre
pardon
qui disaient
d'une voix forte
l'agneau
qui a été immolé
est digne de recevoir
la puissance
la richesse
la sagesse
la force
l'honneur
la gloire
la louange
et toute créature
qui est dans le ciel
sur la terre
sous la terre
et qui est dans la mer
et tous ceux qui se trouvent
je les entends de dire
à celui qui est assis
sur le trône
et à l'agneau
soit la louange
l'honneur
la gloire
la force
au siècle des siècles
et les quatre vivants
êtres vivants
disaient
Amen
et les 24 anciens
se prosternèrent
et adorèrent
voici la vision
béatifique de l'église
les crises glorifiées
qui occupent son lieu
irrésistible des gouvernances
et qui gouvernent
l'univers
en faveur
et à travers l'église
pour l'avancement
de son royaume
et j'espère
que nous
soyons
encouragés
à nous approfondir
et être résolus
à proclamer
ces vérités
avec cette assurance
que nous puissions
chanter
cette réalité glorieuse
que nous puissions
accorder
notre expérience
d'adoration
à ces cultes
célestes
où l'agneau
qui a été immolé
et qui a fait
cette introduction
glorieuse
sur les trônes
des gloires
puisse représenter
notre expérience
sublime
déjà
où est ma vraie
identité
aujourd'hui
cachée en Christ
dans les lieux
célestes
c'est ça
la vérité
la plus importante
à propos
de notre identité
et de ce
qui nous sommes appelés
à faire dans cette vie
donner suite
et continuité
nous exercer
dans une adoration
nous habituer
avec le ciel
pour que
lorsqu'on arrivera
au ciel
on soit
plus capable
de réjouir
tout de suite
de son atmosphère
comme disait
J.C. Ryle
à peine
on pourrait attendre
trouver dans le ciel
des personnes
qui ne respirent
pas l'atmosphère céleste
pendant qu'ils sont
encore dans la terre
et donc
nous devons
nous laisser porter
par cette vérité
sans contredit
le mystère
de la piété
est grand
celui qui a été
manifesté en chair
justifié par l'esprit
vu des anges
et précieux gentils
cru dans les mondes
il a été aussi
élevé dans la gloire
là où il se trouve
aujourd'hui
en tant que
notre médiateur parfait
Amen
et vons-nous pour prier